over the past decade chinese president
xi jinping and russian president
vladimir putin have become close
they made pancakes together
and toasted with vodka
she even presented china's first
friendship medal to putin the alignment
between the two countries is getting
closer and some analysts would say
it's more close than at any point in the
past 60 years
but that relationship is now getting
tested after russia's invasion of
ukraine which has prompted the u.s and
its allies to drop a barrage of
sanctions against moscow
they included hitting russia's energy
industry a major source of the country's
income as well as unplugging the world's
11th largest economy from the global
financial system
but china has taken a different position
as russia's biggest trading partner
china could provide the country with
much needed help by purchasing energy
and providing financial services but the
friendship has limits
one of the biggest hits to russia has
been its energy sector it's the world's
largest natural gas exporter and
produces about 10 percent of the world's
oil and last year total exports reached
about 240 billion dollars
so when putin deployed troops to
breakaway regions of ukraine the west
tried to hit russia where it could hurt
one of the responses that the west has
had to russia's invasion is to
re-examine the energy relationship it
has with russia one of the biggest
re-examinations was the nordstream 2
project a newly built pipeline that was
expected to send 55 billion cubic meters
of natural gas from russia directly to
germany doubling the volume germany said
it would halt the 11 billion project
and as russia has continued bombarding
civilian areas of ukraine the us took
action against russian energy we're
banning all imports of russian oil and
gas and energy
the uk also said it would phase out
russian oil imports while the eu said
it's aiming to cut some imports too
china could help fill some of the gaps
a few weeks before russia's invasion
putin visited the chinese president
ahead of the winter olympics during
their meeting beijing agreed to buy 100
million tons of crude oil from its
neighbor there was another agreement
between russia and china to construct a
new pipeline that would send an
additional 10 billion cubic meters of
natural gas that's on top of an existing
1800 mile pipeline that's already
sending 16 billion cubic meters of
natural gas per year to china but even
with all the planned pipelines running
at full capacity china's purchase would
still fall short of what the nordstream
2 pipeline was expected to send each
year to germany and all of these chinese
projects will take years to fully bear
fruit the deals are significant in size
but they still don't amount to any sort
of immediate economic lifeline for
russia the new pipeline won't be
constructed until 2026 and even the
crude oil deal that will stretch out
over the course of a decade
energy hasn't been the only sector hit
by the west it's also been isolating
russia's financial industry the u.s and
its allies said they would remove seven
russian banks from the global financial
messaging system swift which is used by
more than 11 000 banks and other
organizations in more than 200 countries
and territories and getting excluded
means these banks can't execute
financial transactions meet obligations
or receive payments for exports
practically disconnecting a large part
of russia's economy but china could help
out here too there was speculation that
perhaps china's rival system the
cross-border inter-bank payment system
could provide something of a lifeline to
russian banks
however the chinese system has its own
limitations last year it handled an
average of just 13 000 transactions a
day although the comparison isn't exact
swift processed more than 40 million
messages per day china's system is teeny
at the moment so analysts don't really
think that the chinese system is
um a viable alternative
russian banks could also face problems
with their credit cards visa and
mastercard said they're suspending their
russia operations which practically
blocks many russians from purchasing
goods or services outside the country to
get around this several russian banks
said they were working on the
possibility of issuing cards that used
china's state-owned union pay system
these cards are accepted widely online
and in stores around the world but
switching to this new system would also
take time
there are ways for china to help russia
economically but every time china helps
russia
it risks provoking for the confrontation
with the west
so far china has been trying to strike a
delicate balance it has opposed the
western sanctions
but at the same time it hasn't signaled
that it would be ready to backstop
russia's economy u.s officials said that
russia has also asked china for military
equipment and the white house issued a
warning should they provide military or
other assistance that of course violates
sanctions or
or supports the war effort that there
will be significant consequences
the chinese embassy in the u.s says it
has never heard of such a request from
moscow and china has earlier made vague
pledges to facilitate negotiations to
end the war
the bottom line for china is to ensure
its own strategic interests beijing
wants to keep russia close as a
strategic collaborator against the west
but it's also having to manage its own
relationship with the us and west to
keep that from going off the rails